oh right let's start so good morning
everyone we are here live from panama as
uh we were all the week and it's gonna
be like that for two more weeks guys so
today
uh of course we're gonna first make an
update on amc and gme we're gonna
analyze everything that happened
yesterday guys it was an amazing day we
had some very strong moves so let's go
through through the press action before
market opens guys so we have 10 minutes
left so let's start right now with gme
first then i'm gonna do amc then we're
gonna see if we take some positions
today
um
maybe on gme we're coming close to
support so let's
immediately start the technical analysis
all right so i'm on a daily time frame
guys uh jme first so um
what is interesting here to see is that
of course we are moving uh strongly
higher and we can see that the volume
keeps increasing
um on tuesday we traded 15 million
shares yesterday we traded 25 million
shares guys so this is um
this is the first time we trade that
many shares since
since when since april i think bam bam
bam yes since
okay the 25th of march here on the in
may we traded 21 million shares alright
so since march 21 so it's basically one
year we didn't see such a big interest
in gme so this is the first very
positive thing the second positive thing
is that as you saw yesterday we opened
right on the 120 level we had a quick
battle at japan jimin five ten minutes
at on this level they were best they
were bulls bulls defeated the bears and
we went strongly higher we found some
resistance at 140 level it's a level i
gave you guys i think yesterday before
it was touched uh and
and then we played around this level so
let's go let's go quickly on a 30
minutes time frame because yesterday i
was trading gme and i was using this
time frame
that was to me very useful because the
20 period moving average on this time
frame was supporting the price action at
the end of the session we saw some
decreasing volume on the way up which is
never good um we had a little
bearish divergence that was appearing on
the macd as you can see this goes
together usually with the volume the
volume here was very very big at the
open and then the volume were fading a
little bit as you can see it's not
always like that sometimes at the end of
the session we have some strong volume
coming here it was not the case so um we
played around this
20 period moving average
and yes i'm gonna do amc hey guys what's
up i'm gonna do amc very soon two
minutes left on gme then uh market opens
i want to be done before it starts
um so then we broke
we work out below this uh 20 period
moving average but in aftermarket so i i
don't know how to use the signal there
were absolutely no volume when we broke
out below that level uh
i think that the momentum is broken on
the very short term only
so right now today we are about to
happen uh down five percent something
like this at 133.7
um from for now bulls are still in
control on the
i mean short term
um on the daily time frame definitely so
for the end of the week bulletin control
but on the very very short term if i go
to 30 minutes time frame um we have a
small consideration correction that is
happening for now on low volume so this
is what we want to see this is what
we're going to monitor today we need to
see if basically we are going to correct
a little bit are a lot of investors
going to exit the trade or not is it
going to be a big volume day if we have
a red bar today and it's a low volume i
mean at least much lower than we had uh
yesterday and the day before i'm not
worried the other thing i'm going to pay
attention to is
if we are going to stay above this 130
level uh today i might buy some shares
around 130 because it's the immediate
support
and i think this pullback is going to be
bought quickly okay so one minute left
um
so yeah i'm gonna come back to that but
130 is the first support uh the first
resistance is 147
now right because we had a lot of um
orders executed at this level it was the
high the the highest level we saw
yesterday so this is the resistance i
see for today 147 is the first
resistance 160 let's see what can happen
today guys we can very well have a nice
rebound because the global market is uh
is coming back i'm gonna analyze that as
well we have mixed signal coming from
the global market
um so let's do amc quickly um gme of
course bullish but
today
a bit mixed 130 support 147 resistance
and also this 30 minutes um
[Music]
the 30 minutes turning period moving
average on the 20 minutes time frame is
gonna act as resistance today so let's
see what's going to happen there amc amc
is doing great yet so um like i told you
yesterday
we had a spread between those two and
gme was turning at the premium right
right now free market i have 20 40 and
134
roughly
okay
so let's see
20 40 1224
okay we have a premium at six percent so
a little bit like yesterday at the end
of the session so mc's came back uh
quite strongly yesterday
uh it is so i am right now on hourly
timeframe on the daily timeframe let's
check first quickly
on a daily timeframe guys we have bam
bam bam uh same thing increasing volume
the biggest volume how many shares 170
million shares traded uh it's the
biggest one since okay since august 24th
all right
uh so we still have a lot of room on
this volume um
okay so we went
above the 21 level which was an
important level so yesterday
2018.7 was the support level uh we went
to 21
even 22 got rejected there uh we closed
above 21 which is good right now we are
opening just below so it's a bit a mixed
signal once again just for the short
term of course i mean on the very short
term because on the short term on the
daily time frame as you can see we have
increasing volume the only thing i don't
like here let's be honest is that we
don't have we are not consolidating okay
we need to take a breath so if we have
today
a day where things just pose a little
bit on low volume it's good it's good
for what's gonna happen on friday uh we
need this supposed to happen uh to
happen at some point okay if we want to
go at very high level once again we
cannot go too strongly otherwise it's
not healthy and suddenly everybody's
going to take profits and it's not going
to be looking good
once again because i remind you guys
that in the street there are many many
traders involved and there are also some
asset managers that will not hesitate to
take profit early especially because we
come from the lows as you can see we
have not consolidated at all so a small
consideration is for me good to take so
i don't know what's going to happen i
think that emc is quite strong today
18.7 is the first support do we have
other supports
uh so on the hourly timeframe
i didn't find any moving average that is
respecting well uh that that the price
actually is respecting well
so it's hard to really you know the
hourly time frame 20p removing average
is not too bad we found some support in
pre-market just on it so let's see at 20
so maybe 20 is going to hold
my take is that gme revisits the 120
level today
so it's like a six percent move down
uh
mc might go to
19 point something okay
i don't know i don't have any strong
support around 19. so let's see it's
pretty hard here to measure for now the
bullish momentum is intact on amc to me
okay we didn't have on jamie it has been
broken a little bit
uh but the name see it is still intact
um so let's see what's gonna happen we
need of course to
um to to close again above this i mean
not again but uh the exact level is
20.63 all right so yesterday we closed
above that level why this level once
again i remind you guys that i take the
recent highs okay so my level was around
21 i adjusted it now it's 20.63
and we want the price action to stay
above that level okay because it means
that bulls keep control but once again
if we have today a pose on low volume
it's totally fine to me
okay guys
so
hey brother how are you
dr jimmy always here
okay guys one minute left i'm gonna
place another on gme
because i think that it's interesting to
get some shots today so yesterday i
bought about 27 shares uh i got stopped
before the uh closed around 138 so it
was about 140 i sold 138 it's like a
very fair trade i mean i didn't lose
almost anything so today i'm going to
buy 130 for now i don't want to use
a stop loss i'm going to use the same
position
and i need to see where we consolidate
so then let me place that order
so let's be precise
okay
the exact level where is it we need to
find exactly the consolidation the
support level
so
it's a little bit higher
it's rather
132.6
it's a bit messy what is happening here
i'm trying to find some clear
support levels i would like to have
another moving average helping me here
for now i didn't place any order
i'm still waiting
i'm trying to find another you know i
like to place my orders where i have
um
a confluence of indicators indicating me
that we're gonna
uh that booze are sitting there ready to
buy so we can use fibs as
okay i have here a small um
method for you guys uh if whenever you
see that the bullish momentum is broken
which is the case here once again the
momentum is broken whenever
something regarding the dynamics of the
market is changing so the dynamics are
created by something that is moving so
moving average is a good indicator to
talk about momentum whenever you have a
crossover of the price action with a
moving average you can
talk about
momentum that is shifting so here we
have the momentum that was bullish on
the 30 minutes time frame and it is
shifting because this 30 units time for
uh 20 30 minutes small uh moving average
has been broken so whenever this happens
you can use fibs all right but if i use
flips i measure the whole move up
because we didn't correct from this
whole move up and if i use fibs
it's giving me
123 as a level
so it's a bit low
so i don't like it either but once again
135 i don't have
don't have much so i need to zoom out
sometimes the information is
on
another time frame so let's quickly go
through the different time frames time
frames we have
and i'm trying to once again see
where we have some support on gme
okay
the turning period moving average on the
hourly time frame is not too bad we are
just right now finding some finding some
support on it
um
let's see then i want to talk about the
global market guys i want to talk about
the u.s tenure yield uh the focus today
is uh still on uh inflate inflation
uh on the war
um
so we have still a vix that is quite
high right 23.5 so we are still in an
environment where pretty much everything
can happen
so we're going to discuss all of that
but first guys i would like to find a
good level to buy some jimmy
yeah the best i have
is this
so how what is it 131.3
okay usually whenever you try to find
some support levels doing that
what is good is to
uh really pay attention to the recent
past okay so here on the hourly time
frame i don't have any strong
consideration that's why waiting a
little bit is not bad here i'm gonna
wait if i miss it it's it's fine i i'm i
of course still have uh some jimmy and
amc shares so i'm totally fine if i miss
it
i'm gonna have all the opportunities
later here i don't see clear enough so
i'm not gonna take a position right now
i'm gonna wait i want to see where we
consolidate i want to have more
information i don't see clearly enough
here to take positions so let's wait a
little bit on that
um let me know if you guys have question
uh let's have a look right now at what
happened yesterday on the option market
okay so
let's start with jamie we were having a
dtc did i record it i hope i did we're
having a dtc at 5.2 but once again the
volume is growing
so we don't need to only pay attention
to the dtc we need to look at
everything that is happening especially
the gamma is going to grow
the march 25th expiry is huge guys
so this is going to be important as well
to check what's going to happen there
okay bb-8g of course i'm gonna have a
look guys
okay so i'm retrieving everything as
usual
okay
so the put options are retrieved
okay
the cool options are retrieved as well
okay
so
what do we have here
we have a gamma that is growing guys
yesterday so it was let me refresh that
okay i'm not on the right spot i have
just 15 minutes delay with the spot so
let me just put it
lower we are slightly lower
five percent
okay
okay so the gamma is 4.1 as you can see
the gamma is increasing on the way up we
have
uh
the maximum synthetic shot is at 30
the total number of shares is 19 the
total the total number of options is 19
million yesterday if i remember well it
was 17 million so we have two million
equivalent
shares that were both on the option
market yesterday so that's pretty good
um
okay here the 200 strike is still
sitting at two million let's compare
that to yesterday's information so
woohoo
look at that guys okay
so
what i see here compared to yesterday is
the maximum synthetic shot that grew
from 26 percent to 30
okay
the dtc is lower once again because the
volume is increasing okay so
of course it makes it easier for shorts
to cover so they're gonna less panic
okay the more volume you have the easier
it is to cover for them
so
i don't think
um
i don't think that like seeing this dtc
decreasing is um is not a good signal
for now
but we're gonna keep an eye on it once
again we want to see a ddc around five
six for shorts to be really under
pressure
then the maximum synthetic shot has
increased from 26 to 30 percent so uh it
means that a lot of options have been
both on the very upside
okay
and here current synthetic showed from
five
to four so the synthetic shot has
decreased
which means that i think some put
options have been both as well i'm here
taking uh into account everything so
basically we have a lot of activity on
the option market
and the gamma
is rather stable at four percent which
is very big so whenever the gamma is
that big we can expect some strong moves
to happen in both direction
okay let's have a look at what is
happening
okay so we are
coming to 130 we broke out below this
moving average
but it is not it is not a strong support
um because we didn't have many reactions
many clean reactions in the past so
it's not that much of a problem to me we
came back to 130 so
i didn't buy here
um
it's still a nice support as you can see
on the daily timeframe it's quite
obvious
uh i'm sure
let's let's wait a little bit we have
time
let's wait to to see what the price
action is doing we need once again to
find some consolidations that are going
to help us to know where are located the
bows where are located the best and
usually when the level is touched uh
you know the price action likes to come
back to it at least once or twice before
you know moving from it so i mean when
um an important support is touched so if
130 is really the support and it holds
i'm pretty sure we're going to see it
again
soon so i'm not
rushing i'm just going to wait here bam
amc what is happening on emc guys so i
will eat time frame here i don't have it
like i said any strong moving average so
we got little bit uh rejected
we are turning below 20.6 level so today
18.6 is of course still a good support
level all right so if we come back here
we can buy some shares all right
definitely
because it has here you see the trade is
easier because it has acted very well as
support first as resistance
then i support once twice three four
times okay and i think you remember guys
we bought some shares on amc yesterday
here
hey scott what's up brother yeah guys
please hit that like button it's helping
the channel
and we are here live once again from
panama
let me show you again a little bit
around guys this is the setup we are
having here
so as you can see this is a full trading
desk gabriel once again that is sitting
with me is not here right now
he's you know as usual doing his sport
in the morning he's going to be back
soon
probably uh
have his breakfast as usual
here guys so
um
let's check what is happening on the
rest of the market
here once again i take my time no rush
uh pam pam i wanted to discuss quickly
what is happening on the global market
so
like i said mixed signals mixed stimulus
because
uh triple q triple q as you uh know we
have a support level
that is the previous resistance at 350.
we
touched it
on
monday yesterday we didn't touch it on
tuesday sorry yesterday we didn't touch
it uh but basically every day since
friday we are coming here either the
open or the close okay so it's an
important level and we're still above
that level let me put that in green by
the way
okay
supports are in green so that it's more
easy to understand what is going to
happen bam
okay so um
so triple q is still both are clearly in
control we are above the 20 the 50 day
moving average so it's looking good
um
we needed this small consolidation here
that is for now happening we can even
see a little deep uh it wouldn't be that
much of a problem to me
um but here definitely buzan control we
need to see more what's going to happen
once again my preferred scenario is once
again that we go to 370 so let's see if
we're able to do that
on spy
we
broke out above this 200-day moving
average but on low volume this was on uh
tuesday okay sorry here so this is uh
rather
bullish
but once again whenever breakout happens
without consolidation without volume
guys that's not a very good breakout
okay
so
then we went below we closed below the
200-day moving average
so
it's not a very good signal sent to the
market it's not very bad it didn't
happen on high volume as well but as you
can see the red volume was slightly
higher than the volume the day before
but let's say it's the same
um
and right now that's why it's mixed i
don't know what's gonna happen here we
are we were above then we closed below
now it is acting as resistance we can go
on the hourly time frame
okay
and on the hourly timeframe
you see we are just playing around this
level
so the market likes to you know just
oscillate around those numbers that
act as magnet whenever you have a strong
resistance or strong support where you
have a lot of volume that is involved um
once again this means that this is a
fair price this means that uh usually
this is where
the market likes to come back and this
is what is happening here with the 446
level so
my overall
view on
spy and triple q is
mutual plus okay slightly bullish
because we arrive strongly
we took back some important levels
triple two is still above 350 so rather
bullish but once again we didn't
consolidate
and
we don't have very strong volume once
again on the global market it's totally
fine to see volumes like that because
once again that's i said that yesterday
but i'm going to repeat it it's good for
you
to remember that whenever we are
correcting on for example um spy and
whatever etf of the global market of the
global economy
um there is panic a lot of investors
that usually don't trade arrive on the
market sell their shares all right
sometimes not at the right time but
whatever and then when the market after
the market has finished correcting it is
coming back
taking back some major levels and
usually on decreasing volume if you see
that on a stock it's not good it's not
bullish on the stock you should have
decreasing volume at the end of the
correction then increasing volume but on
the global market you have to you have
things the other way around so you
cannot analyze the volume the same way
but here what we can say
is that
is that this volume is
decreasing
and
i mean
we need sometimes to have a big volume
when we take at least some major levels
this is what is important to know if the
bullish momentum that is coming back is
strong or not so for now here i don't
have the signals so that's why once
again my view is very is really not
strong for now on thus slightly bullish
but rather
neutral
we still have some
tensions you know in between um russia
and the united states
of course about the sanctions um
so we have the inflation issue let's
have a look quickly at the 10-year yield
that is a good representation of the
inflation and it is just moving you know
it is clearly ripping today it it's
taking this week it took nine percent
guys nine percent i mean
when you see this kind of things
it it needs to ring a bell like
something is not right okay because this
is not healthy it doesn't mean that
we're gonna crash or whatever it just
means that you know
there is a lot of tension that investors
are you know
just
rushing to you know selling bones you
know buying equity i mean it's not a
very good environment for um
you know a sustainable rally to occur so
this is the reason why when i see this
kind of things and if i see triple q and
370 spy at 460 i will increase my short
position on the global market for sure
because this is not really healthy but
we understand why we have that okay the
10-year yield represents the inflation
and we start to have some signals
about
not very very good signals i don't know
if you guys pay attention to that
uh this is the curve um
the yield curve
u.s yield curve and
you know it's still in contango which
which means that you know the
short-term interest rates are lower than
the long-term interest rates
and this is the right shape we want to
see on the curve because it makes the
economy easy to function it makes you
know money easy to borrow business easy
to start you know things like that
uh
the the fed is going to have an impact
on the very short term as you are aware
of they control the fed funds which are
the very short term um which are related
to the very short term borrowing
costs uh the long term here so here we
have a 239 this is what i showed you
this is the us 10 year and as you can
see here i don't know if you see well we
have a first inversion of this curve
okay
it's the first time we see that
uh we have the seven year so nobody
really cares about the seven year uh
us
yield but
sorry
them what did they do
okay
but as you can see
it is higher so this some traders
whenever they see the curve inverting
they you know just switch a little bit
and say okay we are bearish so of course
i mean everybody is not like that and
you cannot use the inversion of the of
the curve uh as a signal to trade by
itself but it's just one more
information and we know that the
short-term rates are going to keep
increasing so we know that this
inversion might uh happen on more
different maturities and this is
something we need to keep in mind
because it's having it has a negative
impact on the growth
the other thing i want you to tell you
is that um
yeah we have i mean
for now the global outlook is not very
good to me this inflation is also
weighing on growth and it is the first
time in what 20 years that we have um
you know a negative impact on the growth
once again created by the wall the war
is not good for business created by
uh the inflation because whenever you
have inflation
uh this has a negative impact on the
growth because
the um
the real return of your business is
lower because you need to adjust it
compared to inflation so basically the
growth fitting you have is lower than
the real growth you have you know
something like this i mean economists
have often debated about is inflation
good for growth not a little bit of
inflation is good but too much inflation
is negatively impacting the growth okay
you can have a look at articles about
that if you're interested but this is
what i personally um
use as an information you know whenever
we have too much
inflation
uh it's it's not good for the economy
okay so inflation needs to be controlled
this is the reason why the fed is
actually raising the rates the fed fans
to control you know this inflation they
try to slow down the economy okay this
is what they try to do i mean this is
what they're doing and they don't have a
choice and they know that if they don't
do that inflation is going to have a
very negative impact on the economy so
they prefer to raise interest rates
which is having once again a double
impact on the growth as well it's
more difficult to do business
then nuts but we are in um
[Music]
a situation where we have a wall and it
is once again which is itself has having
a negative impact on the growth so
basically we have three different
reasons
to um
to think that the growth is going to be
impacted negatively this year and uh
which is not good and we see the market
is still rallying so that's why i'm
still a little bit worried about all of
that
um
and and we we are used to see the fed
you know that's coming and saving them
the economy whenever it needs to but
guys for the first time they cannot do
it for now we have a very strong labor
market
uh and
they feel confident to do that fair
enough but
we need to keep in mind that they are
not able to undo what they are doing
right now now the rates need to go
higher so i hope the economy is going to
hold well as i hope the labor market is
going to be good but we have a few
reasons to believe
that all of that is you know at some
point might create some things that are
not good and if this happens the fed is
not going to be able uh to lower the
rates like they want okay so let's see
uh it can of course uh very well
everything can be of course very well um
under control the situation can be
solved uh we need to control inflation
so if the war is uh you know calming a
little bit
and we see the commodity
price is going lower this is going to be
good as well for the economy
it's going to be good for inflation we
need to control inflation okay this is
the main issue we have for the coming
year two years even three years all
right and this is the little game the
fed tries to do guys
so um hey vernon what's up brother yeah
uh all right so uh i'm talking now right
now about commodities so let's have a
look at the community prices first let's
have a look at the vix
uh you know that i'm keeping an eye on
this since uh i started to do some uh
lives with you guys
and because it's once again i'm a
volatility trader ex volatility trader
and the vix is representing the fears
representing the tensions that we can
have in the market
and
avix above 20 means anything can happen
it's a simple rule but trust me it's
working pretty well if you have a mix
below 20 it means that everybody is kind
of you know agrees on the direction if
you have a vix above 23 we can have
strong moves up but we can also have
strong moves down and even if a support
is if your resistance is broken like we
had here
on um
on spy
it can very well fake out uh and you
know for no reason because there is
tension there is fear there is
volatility when there is volatility it's
much harder to you know predict market
movements it's always hard of course and
there is no
way to be
sure of anything but
the increased volatility makes things
even more difficult okay
so
uh this is the reason why i'm neutral on
the global market i mean slightly
positive
then i will do bbag guys i wanted to
check with you the commodity prices
because as you know it's important to
keep an eye on it because the community
prices today impact inflation inflation
impacts the fed policy the fed policy
impacts the growth you know this is all
related so let's have a look at that
i think that oil is still going higher
today
okay and then we're gonna see what
gabriel is making today i can see we see
some green on his piano
so that's
that means i think that
oil is going higher
than
silver okay i think it's silver two
because it's not gold it's not um
oil is down one percent
so let's analyze quickly the situation
we are having here
let me know by the way guys if the live
is good because i see that on my side we
have
some weird things
lagging a little bit
so
please let me know if you see everything
well or let me know the other way around
if you see any issue with the sound with
the image i will restart it quickly let
me know uh
for now i know like i said so 115 is a
natural resistance
okay
let's go again through that together
guys
because this is one more indicator that
you can keep an eye on to try to you
know make your
list of ingredients see what you need
for bull market to be really
um
strong i mean for the probability of a
bull market to be high
uh there are a list of many ingredients
i'm giving you some vics i gave you some
levels on sp y on triple q i told you
about a strong
volume day above a major resistance you
know this kind of things
that are some ingredients that we need
to see all together and whenever you
have you know i don't know amongst your
ingredients let's say 10 ingredients you
have eight of them that are here it's
good enough to have a strong view just
one thing quickly yeah you know in this
gold silver position yeah i think right
now on my side uh i like the ratio so
i'm gonna edge some of it and take
profit
okay so i don't know which level you
entered but because i keep putting in
and on and off okay right now i think
it's for me it's a good level to take
some okay okay so i remind uh everybody
what is happening because maybe you
didn't see what we did on monday
basically we entered silver
uh
and and gabrielle is having a position
he is long silver
short gold he's you know building a
position like that he's increasing he's
taking big sizes and he's increasing
this position if the spread is widening
okay and right now he thinks that the
spread is good enough to uh
to tighten to i mean exit some of his
positions so let's have a look not all
not all a bit because
so i'm happy to take profit sometimes on
the way
and then if it goes back against me then
i can add more okay that's good so how
much money you make today
i mean on the piano i'm 22k okay silver
this is good
i'm about 12k okay okay so 12 000 us
dollars on one trade one position that
he's keeping you know this is good for
you guys to know once again why the
reason why i'm showing you a little bit
what gabrielle is doing is because he's
a personal trader for the past 10 years
uh he has worked for um can i say yeah
for mary lynch uh uh for bank of america
yeah mary lynch
uh and uh the
way he's training is taking spreads okay
everything that is uh what um i mean
getting out of the usual level uh
that is usually happening on the market
is a reason to take a position so for
example gold versus silver and this is a
little bit what we have done uh
yesterday
uh
between amc and jimmy i remind you guys
we bought some amc we sold some gme with
the spread was at 17 or 15 when we when
we did that okay the way we we've done
that let me show that again
is that we found some levels of
equivalence for example 87 is equivalent
to 14.5 130 is equivalent to 21. we
found those levels because we checked in
the past uh how much volume was trading
there and we saw that those strong
support or resistance
attracted a lot of volume and whenever a
lot of volume is printed on some levels
you can consider that this is the fair
price
of those two assets if the correlation
is high enough between those two and
here it's the case between mc and jimmy
and for gold and silver you can do
pretty much the same kind of things and
and right now
see gold is still trading at a premium
but a bit lower than before this is the
reason why gabriel is closing a little
bit of his position on profits then here
let's have a look at the spread between
amc and gme today
gme is still trading at a premium of
seven percent
uh so once again i think that this is
coming from
the option market that as you guys saw
is very animated on
gme
more than on amc especially coming from
the 25th of march option expiry options
so
um
so i think that this is gonna normalize
maybe on monday
all right or next week because next week
there's not and okay let me just finish
the reasoning uh we have so let's check
the chart quickly okay
um
the reason
uh for gme i think to make those strong
moves is once again the gamma so i'm not
sure where the game is coming from some
of you told me it's citadel trying to
create a blue trap maybe but the fact is
that we have a lot of gamma whenever you
have a lot of gamma moves are amplified
right because option market makers need
to buy on the way up sell on the way
down okay to hedge their short
gamma position so this is the reason why
i think jamie moved stronger than amc
and whenever the gamma is not going to
be here anymore things i think are gonna
normalize all right because we saw that
the spread happened uh on monday okay on
monday jme moved by 30 amc only by 15
roughly so we had and before that they
were training at the fair level the
first ratio
so um so right now gm is still trading
at this small premium so there's going
to be a catch up from amc uh i hope on
the way up it can also be on the way
down so let's see
once again for now we didn't take any
position today
because it was unclear
where the support levels were
so let's quickly have a look again
yesterday we were jumping from the 15
minutes time frame to the 30 minutes
time frame
uh so let's do the same thing today so
as you can see
okay for now
for that we have one candle on 30
minutes time frame it's a red one
but what i like to see guys okay let's
analyze everything we are here to make
some technical analysis we're here i'm
here to show you you know all the
different techniques that you can use to
build your view to know a little bit
what the market can do in which
situation build your scenarios
associated with some you know
probabilities
things like that and here the first
information we can have
is the volume traded yesterday
at the open
okay
and the volume 20 today at the open okay
so
the candle has just finished so what did
i tell you at the beginning of the video
guys i told you that a small correction
small consideration is totally fine as
long as it happens on decreasing volume
for now this is exactly what is
happening we have twice less shares
traded today at the open than yesterday
and it is moving down which means that
um
there is some profit taking definitely
that some bulls lost a little bit of
money but much less than uh the ones
that made money the day before right but
i mean we are at the same levels so the
reasoning doesn't really apply in terms
of p l but rather in terms of dynamics
and we can see that we are correcting on
lower volume which is good we want to
see very low volume on red days this is
what we are looking for for strong
and healthy
move up
okay
so
i didn't finish my analysis on the oil
so let's get back to it
bam
okay then i'm gonna take bbig i'm gonna
check
uh
whatever you want guys we're gonna have
a look at silver we bought some silver
as well
okay
okay i'm losing a little bit of money
today but we made a lot
monday tuesday wednesday so it's totally
fine correcting a little bit
i'm checking my positions quickly guys
okay
so
oh yeah let's finish i told you guys
let's go on a weekly timeframe we're
here uh analysing analyzing this move
on the long run because
i mean we had a major breakout
whenever you see those breakouts on very
long time frames on an important asset
like oil you can also think something is
changing right and this breakout was
associated with a move down on the
global market so as long as this
breakout is valid as long as the bullish
momentum that arrived after this
breakout is on the market it's gonna
impact negatively the sentiment okay
that's a fact
and for now this breakout is to me good
quality
holding well uh i bought by the way some
uso on the retest i gave this thread to
my discord as well guys
uh
and i think that so right now what is
happening is that we are retesting the
recent highs
okay so once again resistances are found
using
the levels that act that were that
rejected the price action in the past so
here 115 was the best one because we
have a lot of consolidation in 208 here
and here we have four reactions so it's
the best level i could have and as you
can see it acted once already as
resistance
here
as you can see we closed on friday this
is on weekly time frame and then we
opened uh here so you between friday and
monday here we had a rejection then we
went higher now so we opened here what
i'm talking about let me go back on the
daily but whatever it's not that
important 115 is the resistance level so
right now we are coming back to it
uh so
uh
so it's acting as resistance but once
again as you know the more a support or
resistance is tested the weaker it gets
so it's been twice
we're coming at it
so i don't think it's gonna hold
personally but i'm not surprised to see
some you know ups and downs around this
level
okay
i want to have a look again so let's
quickly finish
so let's quickly finish what is
happening on the oil market once again i
know that you are very interested in amc
jamie
but as you start i mean as you
understand
uh and because i'm talking of it for
quite some time and i mean
it's pretty obvious everything is
related so the community prices are
impacting the global market the global
market sentiment is impacting
uh the you know the profits of big money
players which themselves are not going
to do the same thing with the money
uh like for example investing in amc and
gme all right so what i mean is that we
need a bullish sentiment to be
here
for uh squeeze you know to happen you
cannot squeeze in a bear market
definitely
i mean maybe you could but
it's not really the best uh situation
for squeeze to happen
so let's quickly
have a look again at jme guys we are
here to take some positions today again
for now i didn't take any positions
because
i don't see clearly where the price
action is gonna find support
so i wait a little bit we broke out
below 130
what is it 131
it acted as resistance
right after let's go to 15 minutes time
frame
i think we're gonna have you know
a neutral day we're gonna make some ups
and downs oscillate around this 120
level it's not really a good day you
know to do some day trading because once
again we lost the strong momentum we had
so we need this momentum to come back
and then you can ride the wave again
okay but today i think it's a bit risky
to
to do that
if we see a huge dip of course it's good
good to buy
uh but buying here doesn't seem very
interesting just in terms of day trading
of course for long term view 130 is a
good level to buy and this is what i
shared in my discord as well
uh
i mean i shared it as a support but the
supports i'm giving in my gme recap are
levels that are good to buy on the
medium term
so
let's see let's see what's going to
happen let's go back on a 20 minutes
time frame because once again
what we can do today okay let's do
something
if we see gme taking back the 30 minutes
uh time frame 20 sorry the 20 period
moving average on the 30 minutes time
frame which is right now 137.6
let's say that we try to enter on the
retest of this level because this is the
best
moving average we have we have once
again it is it has been respected very
well during the whole move up
so i'm pretty sure that it's going to be
respected again so my take is that if we
get back to it we're going to have some
rejection and probably some
consideration below and if we have that
and then we move above that with a
little volume increase which would be
enough it means that
you know the very short term
uh momentum is shifting again all right
so we would probably have another leg up
if this happens once again i'm not sure
of anything and if i take some positions
please do not do the same as i do this
is not financial advice this is just an
illustration of the techniques that i
like to use and i think it's interesting
for you guys to see this live to see how
it really works
and and i like to share that so i hope
you enjoy it
bam so bbig i said i'm gonna do it so
let's do bbig
and then i'm gonna have a look at your
questions
so i'm seeing i'm seeing some questions
about the ssr so andrew will you think
ssr will trigger today
so ssrd means synthetic short no
okay can you precise your question i'm
not sure what you mean by ssr i have
some ideas but i'm not sure
okay
so bbig we said
so
okay we're still consolidating
here
but once again this is not a very clean
signal that we had here on vbig
because short selling restriction okay
uh no i don't think so
let's see if it has
let's see
on my interactive broker for now it is
not the case
uh
i don't know maybe
i have no clue let's be honest but i
don't think we had a period
yet where things are totally
uh you know not under control
all right so
once again things start to be hot
but as you can see the dtc is not
you know close to six or seven there is
a lot of gamma okay that's for sure this
is the the parameter that is the hottest
the hotter amongst all the squeeze
parameters the gamma on gme is massive
okay so this is one reason to think that
some you know crazy things can happen
but the other parameters they're not
that hot they're hot definitely all
right we're talking about amc gme
so it's very um
you know those parameters already quite
important even if uh
they're not at the highest levels we've
seen them let me check am secretly
okay so you see did you see a 2.5 so i
mean with the dtc at 2.5 let's add it to
the list and let's check with the past
okay
i didn't add it yesterday but whatever
you see 2.5 guys so it's growing okay
let's add this number
but
not at an impressive
speed okay and once again we need to be
around on amc
at least three four
uh
for the squeeze to really be close for
now we are not there then the
restrictions i i see sometimes them
happening you know
even if things are not really hard so
maybe they're gonna happen it's possible
it's possible
okay
so let's have a look quickly at the
volume trading on amc once again we are
moving lower today so we want to see if
this is happening on low volume or not
okay so the first
hour
is it finished not yet uh no what is
that 8 20.
this was yesterday okay no sorry
okay so same thing as you can see the
volume is much lower than yesterday
so no big deal here
maybe we're gonna revisit the 18.7
level today
okay
let's see
so bbig yeah
so bb-8g
i mean
we are still i mean nothing is happening
here all right so we are still
kind of bulls are keeping control
uh we can see that we are
consolidating
error we can see that we are
consolidating
and once again whenever we consolidate
we want this to happen on lower volume
which is the case here
uh
and
most importantly we are not moving lower
right we stay at
um
at the highest levels we've seen in the
in the
in this recent move up which is bullish
so this is the good the perfect
situation what you know um a rally is
likely to continue whenever you have a
strong move up then oppose at the top
okay with low volume low volatility this
is good
so that the market takes a breath once
again there is a
rotation of investors that take profits
and investors that get in it's healthy
and then you have a breakout on
increasing volume okay this is the
perfect situation so here it looks a
little bit like that on bb ag okay
so let's go on a shorter time frame
let's go the forward time frame
and you see this is exactly what i'm
talking about
we have strong move up on increasing
volume the only bad thing is that strong
volume here red that is not nice to see
okay
uh
bam
then here we have some okay we have a
little bit things that are not good here
you see the market tried to push higher
and got rejected so that's not good
that's created the bearish divergence
once again a bearish divergence occurs
whenever the momentum is shifting down
because the market is making a pose but
the price action is going higher which
means that bulls are trying to take back
control and they're rejected okay if
we are correcting and not making any new
highs then it's a correction but
if we are making lower rise and suddenly
higher high but the momentum is not
kicking in it means that
bulls made an attempt to take back
control and got defeated right that's
how you can interpret a bearish
divergence
so
so it's not good to see
um
so this is the little bad things i would
say about this move on bb-8g okay but
the positive thing is that bulls
maintain uh you know strong pressure on
theirs by keeping the price action at
very high levels compared to what we've
seen in the last week
okay guys so what else can we have a
look at today
okay
we can have a look at the russian index
if you want because i think i'm keeping
it keeping an eye on that
because as you guys know
uh
russia
you know as every country has some debt
the debt of russia is not very high i
think they have
around 23 of the gdp uh i'm not sure you
maybe go and check
uh but
what is happening on the stock market is
of course going to impact the economy if
the stock market plunges totally
which for now we lost 50
60 then we bounced yesterday
and it's gonna make things very
difficult for them to pay back the debt
they have some big
payments to come in april
so of course for example if you see the
russian index dropping by 30 percent
you know
it is just
increasing the probability that they
default
at some point and if they default it's a
very big country
with um
you know even if it's not that
a very big economy it's still much
bigger than any other countries that has
defaulted in the past it would create
substantial tensions in the stock market
so we don't want this to happen so
that's why i'm keeping an eye on that
and for now i just have a basic trend
line on the max guys
and it has been
uh broken on increasing volume all right
so that's not good now we're coming back
to it we found some resistance on it so
let's see if we get rejected
which is likely to happen let's be
honest because of the situation
uh we might drop again so we need to see
what's going to happen even if we drop
if we drop very strongly
uh
guys that will not be looking good all
right okay
so
it was just a quick one let's have a
look at
bitcoin guys so
uh we
we checked that yesterday and i don't
know if you remember what i told you but
i said that 42 is support for d3s
resistance and a scenario where we
oscillate between those two
on low volume is likely to happen and
this is what we're having for now
okay
so we are still stuck a little bit in
this range and you guys know that
whenever the market is trapped not
trapped but you know just is
consolidating in a tight range
at some point on low volume at some
point we have some explosive moves that
arrive so i'm not saying it's ready to
arrive on bitcoin i think we have a few
more days to come but at some point this
market is going to move strongly so
let's see and probably on increasing
volume so we have a good situation for
for example a bullish signal to happen
uh i think that right now the bitcoin
investors are in wait and see mode com
um you know looking at what is happening
in the rest of the economy looking at
what is happening of course on the
equity market you guys know that this is
uh all related it's uh the correlation
between the equity market and the crypto
market is very positive whenever we have
a market crash the bitcoin is not a safe
haven yet maybe it's going to become one
day for now it is not the case
so um
so that's the reason why i think you
know bitcoin investors are still should
we go should we not is it the time for
me it's not the time once again i'm
looking for a massive volume increase
with a breakout so you need to have
those two
uh
signals combined all right a breakout
with that volume is not a good breakout
and the volume increased just random
without any consolidation without any
clear resistance line where we know that
bears were located is pretty much
useless okay it's just creating noise it
is not a good signal to get in so we
need to have the combination of those
two a good trend line with a nice
consideration that is making the bear
camp very visible and then a clear
victory of bulls with increasing volume
that shows that uh
they are back in control and this is
what we are waiting for on bitcoin for
now
it's been what guys it's been four four
months we are correcting it's pretty
long okay i remember when this all
started i told you that the correction
will last
i think i was talking about six months
you can go and check my videos on my
channel still here
my views unchanged i think we still have
a few
weeks maybe month so i i don't see a
strong
breakout with volume happening in the
coming days even weeks i think we have a
little bit more time
uh
unless once again and this is gonna go
together unless we see
uh the sp y and triple q so spy
level to break with increasing volume is
460. if we see that
this would be looking good and on triple
q
the same level is
370 guys so
if triple q goes above 370 spi goes
above 460
then maybe
we can have this you know strong move up
with volume on bitcoin i think this is
gonna go all together and also we're
probably gonna have if this happens
we're probably gonna have you know some
very strong moves happening in cng
probably close to the 30 level on amc
close to 160 gme okay so this is
roughly what we are you know monitoring
on the medium term all right uh time
horizon few weeks few months okay
once again there is no rush this is a
long term play guys
okay
so for now what is the
market doing so spy is still you know
stuck in this range
nothing much
okay
yeah we can have a look at x
once again i did the i did the oil price
oh yeah we said silver and gold so let's
quickly have a look at that
mulan just very quickly not moving much
still stuck between 3 and 360 yesterday
i said that three is a nice support
level that can be used as an entry not
financial advice of course with a stop
loss around 280
you know something like that is the
trade that makes sense now that we're
consolidating there
so let's see
what else yes
so silver and gold let's check slv first
so it's not silver it's the silver etf
plus two percent
so we both
here guys on monday
so we are now positive on this trade we
hesitated to add up more here
okay
we should have
now it's probably gonna just keep
increasing
i think that the second wave pulled back
is complete
so let's quickly
see what we can expect here
okay guys so we had this correction that
lasts for
more than one year one and a half
and right now
let's see we have an impulsive move with
increasing volume as you can see the
volume traded on silver during this
breakout it's the biggest volume we had
for more than a year
so this is telling you that something is
up then whenever you see that you need
to ask yourself are we moving in five
waves or are we moving in three waves
because as you know corrective moves
usually happen in three ways uh whereas
impulsive moves which are the beginning
of a longer term bullish cycle if it's
on the upside usually develop in five
waves so here we can just try to count
the waves it's of course not an exact
science it's just one more thing that we
can
uh
take into account in our analysis so
what do we see here
i for now we are moving in three waves
okay so i think this is a four so let's
see if we're able to make a fifth
if we're able to make a fifth
close to the 26 area
uh then we can expect to pull back maybe
and then probably
more
upside to come
so let's see and by the way on spy i'm
doing
roughly the same kind of
you know i'm using the same kind of
technique
here as you guys know we are monitoring
what is going to happen around the 460
level if we're able to go there so we
did a one
two
okay
already in the last move up on spy guys
daily time frame
um
we are probably doing a third wave so
once again third wave need to involve
huge volume you guys know that but as we
come
after a correction that was a bit you
know um
hard
we know that the volume is slightly
decreasing so we can accept the third
wave doesn't involve a very big volume
but we need to see at some point some
big volume trading here
then we're probably going to go to 460
and correct if this happens and then
only then
if we manage to bam
goes through that level
with a lot of volume because here the
volume would decrease and here we can
have this volume increase in the fifth
wave if we don't have in the third this
would be the signal
that
things are looking really good okay
uh i personally doubt we see that okay
let's be honest i'm more
uh thinking that right now what could
happen is we go to 460 and we get
rejected once again because of
everything i told you at the beginning
of this video because of the inflation
because that is impacting the growth
negatively because of the fed that is
not able to lower the rates to boost the
growth boost the economy by reducing the
boring costs
and by the war that is uh you know just
not good for business not good for
um
for investors you know to just want to
spend the money because whenever you of
course the war is not touching us
directly i mean
you know i'm i'm french so i'm very
close to the conflict but still the
conflict is not in my country especially
now i'm living in panama you guys in the
uh
definitely you know
are not directly impacted that it but as
well but let's be honest it's in
everyone's mind we all discuss it we all
think about do you think a third world
war could happen can putin really use
his nuclear weapons you know
this is something everybody is you know
talking about so
maybe if right now we're not afraid we
are still thinking about it and this has
not a good impact on business on the way
you want to spend your money
uh you know
so i think that we are not for now in a
situation when
just the market can
uh start to
make some crazy moves again on the
long term okay i think we need more time
we need things to
stabilize
we need to see how this is gonna be you
know handled this
whole conflict thing
so yeah this is pretty much the
situation guys let me know if you want
to see something
okay let me have quickly look all right
so bbig i done that
hola hola que tal
okay go to okay bro
go to i can have a look at that
once again we are of course gonna
monitor amc and jamie press action today
guys whole day i mean not whole day but
at least a few hours
and we are trying to buy some jamie
shares yesterday okay this is the
uh what we're gonna try to do but we
need to find the support levels okay go
to
go to attend an education
chinese company something like that
we can say it's consolidating
i mean it's pretty much not moving
anymore it's like looking like it's dead
but it's pretty good actually
to see this kind of pattern
okay
because it's easy to reverse but you
need to have some good things to happen
i mean
fundamental good information good news
about the company or about the
you know
business
around this company whatever some good
news otherwise you cannot just invert
this strong bearish trend
without a good news okay you need
hearing use so let's quickly check if we
have something about go to
i'm gonna go quickly on that because
i don't know if it's
every if it's something everyone wants
to see but it's still interesting to see
how we check all of that
went and
okay it's just the chinese uh
i mean um chinese government that is
buying shares
on the global or the chinese market so
this is good for goku this is the reason
why i think we had this
uh strong move last week of 45
that is definitely not negligible uh
it happened on increasing volume which
is pretty good as well
let's check on the daily time frame what
we have
uh okay so let's do some technical
analysis here let's try to find where
are the resistance levels this
streamline is definitely useless let me
let me get rid of that of that
uh bam bam
i'm trying to find some area of
consolidation
some area of resistance
i don't see anything obvious here the
price action is a little bit
disorganized so
i don't know what to think for me but
the city control we had some nice move
up through but we had that
all the way down guys all the way down
we had sometimes the strong moves up
happening and then bam
it was trading lower again the next days
so
i don't know way too early for me to get
in that
i would like to give you some levels but
i don't see anything
very obvious i would say maybe here
looks like
a good pivot that we need to take back
for for bulls to be in control again so
i i would say that as long as we're
below 240 to 50
burst and control above that level let's
see and if we get above that we're
probably going to be tested so there is
no rush to get it now
i mean there are going to be many
opportunities to get in that trade
probably later
okay
so what else
okay
gme is still consolidating here around
we we we start to have some things guys
okay we were looking for some
information to maybe getting uh gme
we start to have some information here
because the
now it's the 50 period moving average
like 20 minutes time frame just gave us
two nice reactions okay
so
we can start to think that buyers are
located here so we want to be where the
buyers are right we don't we don't want
to be below that we don't want to be
above that or maybe slightly above right
so that we get down on our trades but we
need to be sure we have buyers just
below our
entry levels you know so that the
probability that there is a bounce at
the level we buy is just higher and for
now it is to me still unclear where they
are it seems a little bit disorganized
but the best information i have for now
is that they're located around the uh
128th level okay so not rocket science
as you can see it's just where the price
action was during the beginning of the
day but you need to understand why it is
here and what is creating the supports
all right so that you can follow that
this is how i like to work okay and give
me some likes guys i can see 64
going up slowly but surely come on hit
that like button
it's good for the channel
okay
so what else do we have let me have a
look quickly at your questions
okay
thank you guys for the support i really
appreciate that
any opinion on vxx so if i am correct
it's the short vixx
let me check i'm not sure
yes
vixx short-term futures so i mean i can
do some analysis on the vix on the vxx
if you wish
it's pretty much the same thing that i'm
gonna give you on the vix okay
but let's do the xx if you prefer
interesting
no sorry it's not
it's short-term futures ah okay sorry
it's not okay to show dicks all right so
um
okay so the first thing you need to know
about
the vix futures
is that
usually on the equity market
you have
the spot i mean this the spot price the
stock price that is converging towards
the forward price which is the same
price minus the
dividends minus the repo okay just to
make it clear
basically
you uh
i mean on the vix it's the other way
around so whenever you buy that
you gonna
if nothing happens on the vix
you're gonna converge towards the vix
all right so you need to know that what
you buy
is going to move
down with time because here the vix is
trading at 23
okay
and this is a future price
and this future
is going to converge towards towards the
spot price the spread price is the fixed
price which is at 23. so you need to
know that if nothing happens on the vix
if the vix is stable
you're gonna lose money okay
so you are basically
uh
the time is playing against you whenever
you buy this thing so this is a trap
that a lot of investors fall in because
you think that if the vix
is not going to move you're not going to
lose money but you will all right so be
careful when you trade this instrument
that to me
very
you know i would say sophisticated
instrument complicated so you need to be
aware how this is working
and
the best thing i could say is that as
long as the vix is at 23
first if it's not moving you're gonna
lose money second
the support is not 23 it's 20. so we
still have three points
lower to come on the vix before being at
the support level and as you can see the
support level was hit in feb 22.
so
i wouldn't rush at all into this
instrument i would
wait
definitely
uh
before doing anything here because like
we saw
on the global market we have some
you know
stability that is coming back we took
back some major levels and we are now
consolidating and once again my take is
that we ground higher to 370. so if i'm
correct about that it means that the vix
will probably drop to 20 so the vxx will
probably drop to 21.22
right so it's too early to get in
uh
okay
and
and yeah that's all i can tell you about
the vxx
okay
so
all right so i'm having question of so
tal
clvs and
roots okay so let's go through that guys
hey paula
the best you here how are you
i hope you're enjoying this
it's nice to see you as always thank you
for being here so let me know if you
want to see something of course
uh all right so like we said
tal all right so t-a-l let's do that
okay so still the same kind of you know
stock that is moving down tell education
group okay it seems a little bit like
go-to in terms of technicals education
as well
let's check what they do
i don't know this company
okay tal education group provides
educational services the company offers
comprehensive tutoring services to
students covering core academy subjects
such as mathematics english
okay
okay fair enough
uh technically
they are not
doing amazing
uh volume is still low we start to see
some volume increase on the way up which
is good but i would say that as long as
we stay below this blue trend line
around 360 bears and control
and even if we take it back
it's probably going to take some time to
revert okay
the bearish uh momentum is strong here
and we need something strong to tackle
it all right
so
nothing more to say here
pam pam pam we can have a look at clvs
okay
and then we're gonna
go back to emc and jamie see what is
happening there because amc is coming
back guys to the 18.7 level
very
soon it has
traded
what level
18.86
it's tempting to buy some shares here
guys let's be honest
what is the premium between those two
still the same for now
because i prefer to buy
the one that is undervalued so here amc
seems undervalued compared to gme once
again the premium is eight percent now
so i prefer to buy some emc shares then
some dmi shells at this levels
okay
sorry i lost my mouse okay
okay
i'm gonna do your technical analysis
soon i'm just checking if i take some
position on amc
uh
it's tempting
okay i know what i'm gonna do yesterday
i sold some calls
for those who are with me in discord you
saw that
so i can take profits here i sold them
at 225 they are now worth
125. so i'm just gonna buy bait back
okay so i'm going to place an order on
that
so 123 so let me check the delta because
i want to do that 0.6 points lower
so this is the position i had
okay i sold some april call 25
okay and the idea is of course to buy it
back on the dip so now we have a dip so
let's buy it back
all right
so
amc is turning at 19.3 i'm checking the
price 143 but if we go
three percent lower
they're losing
0.2 okay so they're gonna be 20 cents
cheaper they're right now trading live
at 127 so i'm gonna buy it at 107. okay
i'm gonna get the two of them
okay so it's not amazing profit guys but
it's still
you know 200 us dollars
okay so i'm buying that guys
at 107. all the places okay let's see
and we keep an eye on everything else
guys if i see any other opportunities
somewhere else i can take a position
like i said bbig is not perfect
we can have a look at the rest of the
market as well so clvs proof serious
guess i was making some tier about on
clds long long time ago
and you know i was bullish on that
i was hoping for an upset breakout but
unfortunately we had a downside breakout
in august 21.
uh since then it's just um
not looking good at all so right now to
me
there's nothing much to do here the best
thing to do is to wait and see what can
happen at higher levels i mean you can
still make a short term bullish trade
but
here time is going against you as well
because blessing control and the gaining
ground every week
so
buying here is just not the best you
know
place to put your money i think
it's better to buy something that is hot
not something that is dropping okay
so here we need to wait for some bullish
signals to arrive on the medium term at
least
so that you know your investment stays
at least stable you don't want to put
your money in something that is
constantly dropping it's
not good to do
so here we need to wait we have
indeed some volume increase okay
so all right something happened here
but
a volume increase without the breakouts
like i said it's just creating noise
it's it's not a buying signal and here i
don't see any breakout i don't even have
a clear trend line all right so
uh
bam i can draw maybe a line here but
even if it's broken it's not going to be
you know
there are many resistance on the way up
here so i would say the first resistance
is 180
so let's see if we're able to trade
above 180 if we do come back to me i
will have a look
uh okay can you check bitcoin bro
you can play back if you want i just
made an analysis about that so
let me know if you see it i can just of
course quickly remind you what i said is
that 43 is resistance created by this
trend line 42 was resistance it is now
support on the very short term uh we are
oscillating between those two levels on
low volume so let's see if the market
takes the direction
i give it personally a few more weeks
before really turning bullish i can
change my mind if i see
some very strong volume happening with a
breakout so for example if suddenly we
trade at 45 000 with a massive volume
uh this would be to me considered as a
valid bullish signal
and
and i would turn bullish on the medium
long term for now i'm mutual i think
we're gonna keep moving sideways
and of course if we have a market crash
we have a lot of downside on the bitcoin
so
it's hard to monitor that
because we don't have any clear support
on the way down but i would say that
below this trend line
we need to start being careful
so
you know roughly below 38 37 000
if we go below this levels
we might you know revisit really the
lows like 29 000. for now we are uh on
the other side we are close to 43 000
so we are looking good but once again
uh to me we're not out of troubles on
the global market for the reason i gave
you guys before
okay
i hope i didn't miss my amc trade guys
for now of of course not executed but
it's fine
let's wait
okay
so bitcoin is done
so you would you take a gender a tesla
it's hard it's true run
just for you
okay so i discussed tesla yesterday we
can have a look at it today again tesla
is of course a very interesting stock
credit
check i actually pay you
don't know
[Music]
okay let's have a look at tesla and we
have some news coming from gabriel yes
he wants to show us something so let's
have a look at that as well
i don't receive
ah because there is a link i think you
are not allowed youtube is maybe
blocking you
ah okay well just you should just go on
uh
well i'm gonna send it to you
differently yeah it's just because of
something you uh yeah okay gabriel has
something for us guys so
yeah
okay because we were discussing this
morning as usual guys when we wake up we
are traders we discussed the news we
discussed the market and we were
discussing this morning what could
happen if russia defaults all right so
it's just what's interesting is just the
probabilities that the market is showing
there okay so what should i be looking
at what's what's the most interesting
part is really basically this one okay
so russia credit risk surges all right
of course as putin's demands renew
default fears okay and the interesting
part is credit default swap protecting
10 million us dollars of the
government's bond for five years were
quoted at about 6.4 million up front and
hundred thousand annually okay guys so
this
uh
credit default swaps are protection that
investors buy against the default and
whenever you know the price of this
instrument you can imply the probability
of default of russia and this is what
has been done here that implies 87
probability of default
wow
so much it's weird yeah i mean it's like
almost sure they're gonna divorce me
yeah that would the client pay the
stupid price you know maybe he was like
really scared because i think no one
wants to sell that
so that's why they he paid a huge
premium for that yes this is a good
example of you know the premium that
investors that are seeking protection
are paying here there was an investor
that was seeking protection against a
russia
default okay he bought a cds
and when we checked the probability
implied from the price he bought we have
an 87 property of default of course we
can assume it is less and whenever you
buy options on the an amc
uh and amc is just rallying like now
it's the same things that are happening
because it's optional market makers are
not using a probability of default
they're using a volatility and they're
going to put it at crazy stupid levels
because they know that retail investors
are going to buy it here and nobody
wants to sell it so just a quick
reminder this is the reason why i prefer
to buy shares and sell calls whenever we
move strongly higher because buying
those calls is a scam that is done by
option market makers but it's totally
legal because they have a bid price and
an offer price so you can sell it as
well this is what i personally do okay
just a small uh thing i wanted to show
you so here it's interesting to see that
the probability of default
is whatever if it's 87
or if it is
uh
50
i don't know even maybe 30 it's huge
guys it's huge and i wonder so let me
know guys if you have some view about
that i wonder what would happen if
russia defaults okay
uh
i think it can be really really really
bad
because once again it's a big country
and we i think we don't measure the
impact of such an event and i'm
surprised the market is not concerned by
that to be honest i don't see news about
that i don't know if you guys heard of
heard something about this
uh i mean i think is a way to default on
one of their payments yeah they still
kind of close things they have one month
to make a wall i think let's see convert
something like this so maybe as long as
they don't default
and that basically you don't have like
this one month kind of you know
the ultimate of this one month maybe the
market is not stressing
i may be wrong
i think i heard something like this
that's a very good uh point indeed so
uh indeed if there is a one month delay
added to you know uh after they
officially default
then the market is gonna start to get
concerned once they do that and once
again in april we have some big uh
payments that should happen
so let's see let me have a quick look at
this article that we're gonna have we're
gonna find some news one your contract
rules blah blah blah
okay we have some news about scott baker
40 days grace period like every grand
okay yeah totally i agree makes sense
i didn't really see anything else in the
article that was kind of worth
mentioning like the only thing that
interesting was the probability okay
okay okay okay but let's guide and so
guys let's monitor all of that all right
so tesla bam what's happening on tesla
guys so
uh
so we are i did tesla yesterday so i'm
gonna pretty much say the same thing but
maybe you were not here
so here the situation is that indeed we
are moving higher but we wonder if we're
gonna develop in three waves or five
waves just like on spy
just like on many different stocks so if
we for now we have a very strong move
here it looks like a three let's be
honest okay
so bam
if i do some elliot wave counting here i
would rather label that and we have
increasing volume okay this is looking
quite good all right
so let's see if we move in abc or in one
two three four five in both cases i
think we might go to hundred and hundred
so we have a ten percent move up to take
but i would personally not buy here the
reason being that there is no support
there is no consideration to help me
build a pr uh
uh to
create a trade and with a stop loss that
i would place just below the
consideration
so i wouldn't i don't know i would wait
you know if i missed the move it's fine
but buying here is not
very appropriate to me
resistance is 100 and 1100 so let's see
what happens if we manage to go there
probably rejection and then
uh
then if we have this
fifth wave through
this 1100 level
uh this would be a very good signal that
uh you know things
are starting to look very bullish again
but
okay the good thing about that let me
keep discounting it's quite good i have
to hear my two scenarios either we do an
a b c or
the abc is complete and we're doing a
one two three four five that is gonna be
followed by more upside after that
probably uh so here the first thing i
see is the growing volume okay
on the way up so it's good as you guys
know we're wondering if we're in the b
wave or if we are in an impulse right
and okay we don't know if it's this
scenario or this or that scenario and in
an impulse you guys know that we need to
see increasing volume and here we have
it so it might be an impulse now let's
check another b wave and let's compare
it to the b wave we have here because
once again there is a lot of information
in the past
let's just use it here we have a b wave
okay look at that
a
b c
so let's check the difference between
this
and this
in terms of volume so the volume
associated is here
okay decreasing
and indeed here it is increasing
okay
let me just make sure i'm
checking the right
candles
okay the b wave is here from here
to here
okay we have
slightly increasing as well guys but not
as nicely as here
okay so i would say that this looks much
more impulsive
than what we had before so the
probability that it is
a new
impulse is higher but once again this is
only one information that we have it's
not enough to uh
to have a strong view
we need to associate to combine that
with the other indicators that we're
looking at
okay so the max is looking good uh we
need
we need a breakout guys okay we need a
breakout somewhere to happen
so let's see but it's not looking too
bad okay if i had to choose should you
buy or sell tesla today i would buy it
okay but once again the setup is not
good enough in terms of risk reward for
me to get in this trade
okay
okay guys so
what else amc
amc still
coming
you know oscillating around this
50 period moving average under 30
minutes time frame
gme as well
testing this level so let's see what's
gonna happen
here okay oh bitcoin is starting to move
up
yeah i wanted to tell you but i mean i
was looking at volume i didn't see the
volume yet so i thought i would not
mention to you okay
indeed
so let's see let's see what happens
indeed we have
for the first time
a quite good move above the 43 level we
had that actually before as well little
bit here guys
so let's see if the signal can be good
quality or not
we add this here
okay
we have a little volume increase on the
15 minutes time frame yeah but is it
finished or not
we still have three minutes left so
let's see
because you kind of have bars that are
similar if you look like where
where is this yeah here yeah yeah no no
definitely i agree
uh i agree this is not a massive volume
it's we had this multiple times before
uh we would like for this
first i'm looking at breakout on the 15
minutes time frame we are talking to you
guys about the three months correction
so of course i'm not using the right
time frame but i just want to zoom in to
you know see what is happening and only
15 minutes time frame we have some
volume but for this breakout to be
validated and by the way guys if you are
interested to know what time frame you
need to use i'm explaining everything in
my calls guys so just go on my website
grab your course join the community come
to see me on discord guys
i'm gonna share with you some trade
alerts and i'm gonna try to teach you
everything i know this is the purpose of
this channel so here uh the time frame
we're using is just not right so let's
go on the daily
the daily time frame is the appropriate
one you see we we start to move higher
but of course
we have some volume on the 15 minutes
time frame but let's see if this volume
is gonna last whole day
uh
i don't know
i don't know so let's see what's gonna
happen at the end of the day if we're
able to close that i don't know maybe
forty three forty four
forty five forty forty four forty five
sorry
but on the hour little time frame we
have a valid pattern here to me
okay
what is the thicker for bitcoin
here btc no no no no no
no no
um
so let's see beto which is the etf
because guys we're here to do some day
trading so
maybe we can
see if there is something to do
on
bitcoin so here you can see as well we
have a small volume increase here the
pattern is not
very nice
okay
because of course it's not as nice as on
bitcoin because
bitcoin is training non-stop here we had
us um
we we
we only see the u.s training hours
okay let's wait a bit let's see if this
breakout is good quality
for now
i mean on the
medium term it's not going to be enough
during the day we need to wait until
tomorrow to see if it holds but during
the day we can try to play it
so what we're going to do we're going to
wait
uh for re-test and we can try to set up
an order here all right guys so this is
going to be the second trade of the day
i remind you we are trying to buy some
calls on amc 25th 25 strike call on
april maturity that to try to buy at 1
107. okay i'm not financial advice but
this is what i'm trying to do which is
uh basically
equivalent around bank amc around 18.7
just like we did yesterday which was a
good trade okay
so
okay so you see today we're losing a
little bit but i remind you guys
yesterday we made 10k
thus our hong kong dollars
today losing 3.5
no big deal okay so beto
okay so let's try to find the equivalent
level of b2
okay it's 27 all right
okay
so now we need to find where we put our
stop loss
uh so the stop loss needs to be just
below this consolidation here
i like this setup once again on the
hourly timeframe because
we have clearly a nice consideration
here with many reactions the only thing
that doesn't make this very clean
is this little you know move here
that is making it harder for us to place
our stop loss so we're to place the stop
loss roughly below this
okay
so around 42 500 so below the recent law
okay
simple
so let's do that guys let's place an
order we're going to compute the size so
the recent law here is
at 26
roughly 26.8
okay
once again guys to place your stop loss
you can use different methods and the
best thing is to associate all of this
method together so we have a look at
support trend lines trendline support we
have a look at moving averages
okay
here i don't know which one is actually
the best as support
looks like the 50
not perfect
i'm going to change the time frame see
if i have a better moving average to use
not really
30 minutes time frame it's always like
that guys you need to check change
switch from one time frame to the other
one but first you need to know which
time frame you should use for your
breakout
okay
and this is only about experience okay
there is no
magic formula by that
every trader has its own rules i
explained my rules in my course of
course
some trailers do differently
i want to take some leverage guys so you
i want to have a tight stop loss all
right so
i think
26.8
makes sense
i also want to see if it's a one-to-one
relation between those two so
17
since the low
and bitcoin took
17 perfect so it's a one-to-one relation
all right so here
just to make sure
between this price and the low i have
two percent
and on beto
between the price and the low i have
okay it's this slow okay 2.6 okay so we
have our levels so we're going to try to
get in at
27.1
stop loss
26 pounds
okay let's be just here 26.7
okay so let's compute
the position
so entry
27.1
stop loss 20.
six points come on let's do six
okay so risk
per share
is equal to this divided by this okay
so one
no sorry divided minus
okay
um
total risk
let's do as usual 250 us dollars
so divided by that so we go for 500
shares guys all right
so we have our order
and we're going to discuss targets later
okay so this is some day trading so
we're going to close this position today
we don't want to be exposed to a risk to
a gap risk tomorrow
uh so let's do that guys 27.1 26.6 let
me check again quickly the levels all
the the right levels for this trade
we might also just ready if we miss it
we miss it it's fine
okay it's good
all right let's set set this up guys so
what position we have
okay it's around
30 or 13
000 us dollars guys
let's compute that
to be sure what we're doing so national
is
500 times the entry
13 000 like i said
so you can see guys we are only risking
250 dollars
but we take a position of 30 13 000 us
dollars all right so let's check the
leverage we take by doing this type of
trade
we are
risking
250 where is
uh no total risk i put 500 now okay 250.
it's equal to 250
that equal that divided by 250. okay we
have a 55
times leverage okay you can see things a
little bit like that
and we build this
you know just
by using a stop loss
so we buy 500 shares
27.1
i had i had that before
uh
okay i need to call interactive broker
it worked it's weird
gbtc have the same issue sometimes you
know
you need to ask for permission to trade
not show the ball okay and this one
okay
let me check if i can
do the trend on gbtc it is working as
well
and you can use you cannot use the stop
loss on kraken okay
so 29 okay i try
no trading permission okay so i need to
call interactive broker
but i cannot call them
uh
okay let me call them guys i'm gonna
stop the webcam quickly
now it's gonna be a pain guys i don't
wanna do that it's going to be really
painful for you to
listen to that
uh
i think i can ask the permission by
myself but i don't know where it is
i'm surprised you cannot do that
let me check if i can do it on my
account
okay
what do you want to do sell beethoven
i've done that before i traded some
i had some gbtc on my account i had the
permission
and i traded some bto options even
so i know i can do this
i've done that before but you know
sometimes you have the permission and
then it just goes you need to ask for it
so gabrielle is opening his interactive
broker account let's see if he can take
the trade for me
he's gonna be same if i win
you know
he's gonna give me the money if i lose
i'm gonna give him the money
okay guys but the order is ready
let's hope we don't miss it let's hope
we can do it
it's a risk again because we've seen a
lot of fake outs on bitcoin but we're
here to play guys we're here to have fun
okay we made some money this week so we
can
take some risk
oh right
i have no problem placing an order okay
cool
did you try is it you sure it's the
restriction and not it's not a limited
issue because they may be
requesting like hundred percent credit
yeah
just try to buy one share at 25
just uh okay
matter of testing yeah you're right
okay
but i know i am illegible it's stupid
i mean
it's up to you i don't know if
if you want me to trade i can trade okay
let's do that
so we place the order on gabriel's
trading account
so we buy
500 shares
27.1
okay
that's it yep and then stop loss
sell
but it's not executed no no i know
i'll do it when it's done it's better
okay all right i mean it doesn't change
anything okay
orders place guys so that's done
i'll let you know whenever it's executed
okay
silver is moving nicely today guys we're
bullish on this
okay
ah
amc cool was that did you guys already
get in
okay so yeah the mc cool paula to answer
your question is the april 25 call
i'm gonna try to buy that but just to
make it clear it's something i sold
yesterday so i'm buying it back lower uh
but we can quickly discuss what kind of
options is good to do on amc
for those who are interested
so the 25 call if if i was not short i
wouldn't buy this one i would rather go
to a smaller strike
i would go maybe to the 20
the 25 is not that bad let's be honest
but 25 is actually a resistance so we
might go there and get rejected
so it's better to get in on the 21
strike
okay but you have less leverage so let's
compare those two strategy okay let's go
on apple
and once again the volatility is quite
high so i also explained that i prefer
to sell options whenever we move
strongly than buying them
um
okay
let's check the difference between those
two strategies
okay so as you can see here i'm having
okay so one
uh
april 25 call so this is the
um present value and payoff at maturity
so the present value is
let me zoom in here a little bit
is basically what it is worth so right
now it is worth around 150 us dollars we
are here so if we go on the upside you
can for example if we go at 40 you can
make up to 1 400 us dollars but let's be
honest foodie is uh
you know quite far
let's check that things like that okay
bam
okay
so
um so this is the profit you can make on
this position and right now if you go
then you start to make money only after
25 okay so if you close below 25 you
don't make anything whereas if you go to
a 21 strike how much does it cost what
is the difference in price
it's 2.3 so let's say you do the same
amount
so 2.3 divided by 1.5
okay 1.5 so it's equivalent to 1.5 so
let's do things like that
first if you buy one and a half
call which is not possible but at least
we invest the same premium
uh as you can see if we close at 25 you
don't make anything but if we close at
30 you make 900 us dollars okay for
example at 30 and i think that it's hard
we close above 30. so let's set today is
the best case scenario so at 30 you make
900 us dollars and you invested
it's the
it's the pml okay so you make 900 us
dollars profit now if you go to a 21
call and you invest the same amount
which is 220 us dollars
okay so the same amount and we said at
30 you make
800 us dollars so there is not a big
difference at 30. you make a little bit
less on the 21 call but just a little
bit and
but you make
more money between 21
it's a 21 strike and 25 which is an area
that is very likely we
finish in uh on april uh april 14th i
mean it's more likely because it's just
closer so to me this is showing clearly
that it's better to go to a lower strike
that has a lower uh volatility even if
the volatility is crazy high 160
is extremely high so that's why it's
better to sell those options than buying
them but whatever
now you can also compare by doing the
spread look at the difference
okay so this is the difference between
one strategy and the other one and you
can see that the difference happens
between 21 and roughly
after 21 and you are better off
to make
until here until 29 you are better off
with the 21 call all right so to answer
the questions what is the best call
option to buy today on april i would say
21 cold
and the price is around 200 us dollars
now
i would personally not do this strategy
by itself because the vault is very very
expensive so the best thing to do
i think is to buy the scroll
all right
and to as the volatility is very high we
need to buy some volatility and sell
some volatility and i understand you
don't want to sell sell some more upside
calls because if we squeeze you want to
have the full upside performance and you
are right so we will not sell a higher
call but we can sell a put so what kind
of food can we sell we need to go for
a support that we have and the strongest
support we have today
is created by the breakout area okay
so the breakout area is
here at 16.7
so selling a 16 puts makes total sense
so this is a good option strategy on amc
that is not losing anything until 16.
okay
so it's buying 121 call and sending one
okay
and here
okay
you you just divide your premium by two
so you still spend some money but less
okay so i think that this is a good
strategy buying the 21 call selling the
16 put
oh right
let's go on a chart
let's check what is happening right now
guys we have some
we have some moves
okay
boos are trying to take back control
let's see for now this is still early
here the 50-day moving average acted
well as support we didn't take any order
yet
because things are not clear enough for
us to support but we had four reactions
on it
so
let's wait a bit we said that we're
gonna see how the 30
minutes time frame 20 period moving
average is going to act today it was a
support yesterday
uh let's see if it's going to act as
resistance today i'm afraid it will
okay for now bitcoin is pushing higher
can you look up ethereum classic chart
i wonder it can go last
highest
okay
okay
foreign
usd okay let's have a look at that
indeed we had some massive move up
happening recently
okay i don't know so etc usd
okay i don't have any technical analysis
here i'm surprised because i think
i think
right now i'm on binance i think
i can check kraken i wasn't banned
i came to kraken but
maybe not
okay
so we indeed have some massive moves
happening here guys
so wherever you have some massive moves
so let's go on which exchange do you
think is the most traded one
i mean any other big one would be fine
it could be finance coinbase uh kraken
okay uh
ftx so we want to see we have some
volume increase and look at that gates
bam so this is a very nice volume
increase this looks like the beginning
of something but like we said before a
volume increase is good but needs to be
combined with a breakout okay
and here
do you see a breakout i think i see one
okay
not very good because for breakup to be
good quality we need to have a
consolidation that is showing that the
trendline you're using is followed by
other investors
here the best i can do is that and it's
not very good so here the signal is to
me not
perfect definitely so it's bullish i
prefer to buy it than selling it
uh but i would not set up a trade here
personally just because the setup is not
uh perfect uh
basically what could happen so for now
bitcoin is you know going higher but
let's see this is a 15 minute breakout
on the three months correction so it's
of course not enough
uh if we dump here etc will dump
probably stronger
because it moved just stronger recently
where is the atc
so we are bullish but the bulls
control is fragile and
it's fragile because we didn't
consolidate anywhere so if we see a
consideration happening now above this
200-day moving average around the 40
level
it would you know we have look at the
rsi guys the rsm the daily time frame is
overbought but whenever you have an
overbought rsi with strong volume it can
still go higher i mean it can always go
higher but the probability it goes
higher is
more important
so here definitely both are in full
control
uh
okay
if you want to do some day trading it's
i think a good asset
because we're probably going to have
some buy the deepers all the way up
okay we can try to go from one time
frame to the other one and see what
levels
are
good
uh wet moving averages are good to use
nothing here
30 minutes time frame 15 minutes time
frame nothing here
i will eat them frame
same we don't see anything
i don't have anything so
i mean whatever we use we can see the
bullish momentum has been here a little
bit broken so we corrected
so uh
so i would say that we need to have a
breakout
on the short term but breakouts on the
hourly timeframe on
you know a crypto that is moving that
much is a bit risky but here we have a
signal you can have a trend line that
you use here and here you have a small
volume increase so i would say that if
you want to place
you see a small volume increase but look
at that guys it's very small compared to
the volume we had here so this is weak
so this signal is not good quality let's
be honest it's not tradable to me
but i'm just showing you what we would
have liked to see if here we had a
massive volume of course this so
probably would be here
much higher and this would be a better
situation to get in here this is not
very interesting to buy
uh
so yeah
we are bullish but
nothing very easy to set up a trade for
now
we have some support at 41 so let's be
more precise here
so the support can be used to set up a
trade
but yeah no it was coming from the
stream land and we didn't have the
consideration it's risky guys i don't
see any nice trade setup here to be done
definitely and if i go back on a 15
minutes time frame it was the best one
we have this but it's not strong so okay
it's bullish guys but to me the um we
don't have enough indicator pointing
towards the same direction for us to
open a position here okay look at the i
don't know just association maybe look
at what hrm is doing
okay because there is usually some kind
of misery correlation there could be it
could be some kind of delay like if
ethereum was really rallying strong
which i don't think it is
uh like you could see a delay on a term
classic because people think you know
it's the next one
so if they you see some kind of
indication that ethereum
maybe you can dedicate something is
going to start on nature and do you
think we can try to make some um premium
strategy like
for example that etc is trading higher
than you know that one is ahead of the
other one or i mean you i would not
really do some kind of uh like the gold
silver ratio on this one
okay but if say i mean my my view is
that if ethereum say was like in the
last i don't know two weeks or so it was
at 30 percent 40 percent and a term
classic was late then you could expect a
pump network plastic
but i don't think we i mean no way not
in this scenario but then you could just
double check it so it's interesting of
course let's have a look at that guys so
you guys know that
etc usd is like you know
the little sister little brother of
ethereum so let's have a look at
the big guy here
let's keep those two charts together
by the way vixx is dropping guys
spy is going higher
we have some relief
by the deepest we're active today
i think we're going to push higher or
right so
if the h2sd
so ethereum usd has a little bit the
same shape as bitcoin
uh because those two
big market caps are
very
um
correlate a lot now
i mean if you want to look at it as is
bitcoin you could also look there is
there should be a ticker on the
on uh
on trading view which is a terrorist
bitcoin like how many ether you get for
bitcoin although reverse yeah the ratio
right and then um this is another thing
you could look at is you know if 80 rm
is late compared to bitcoin in this
new rally yeah
sometimes you could just you know switch
one this is the other true okay but
let's check that as well guys let's talk
a little bit about cryptos right now so
um first we can see that to me when i
look at the charts they are
synchronized synchronized yeah because
we just have right now the
you know
uh breakout attempt on ethereum above
three thousand
okay so let's see if volume is kicking
in
and on bitcoin
we have the same above forty three
thousand okay so to me
they're really moving together
but apparently there is an indicator
that is making the difference of those
two so let's try to have a look at that
i'm not sure i can find it so
bitcoin
how do you think it's called
just type eth space btc ah okay and then
you'll probably find it
btct
[Music]
okay
so
interesting so we can see indeed looking
at that
it's funny because it has the same shape
as
ethereum itself and as bitcoin itself so
basically we can see that moves are
amplified on this so we can
assume
that
if there is a rally
that we're gonna have here a breakout as
well which is
telling me that it is better to buy
ethereum than buying bitcoin today
because if we get back to those high
levels we've seen before and if we have
a real rally coming back on the crypto
market we can expect this
ethereum bitcoin
pair
to as well break out because we can see
it's very correlated you guys
remember what is that this is the
bitcoin move this is the ethereum move
so here we don't have a breakout though
but definitely if i need to buy
something today it's ethereum but
i don't know if we have a ticker on that
on
interactive broker ethereum
uh
yes uh give me a second okay
so we're gonna check maybe we're gonna
change our order on beto to uh an order
on
ethereum
um etf let's see if we can find that for
now
it's just
uh going up without us it happens
but once again guys don't rush into
those breakouts because this market is
very volatile it's better to miss
sometimes a trade
than over trading and you know losing
money
so all right let's check amc is doing
well as well getting back
to the 21 level maybe soon
it's a pain we missed our trade here for
not a lot
maybe word bit greedy but whatever we'll
see maybe we're gonna have another
opportunity and give me some likes guys
i can see it's growing but we are still
at 83 likes guys you can do better than
that let's go 200.
okay so what else i wanted to show you
probably the bay the best would be
what's called the grayscale ethereum
trust
which is e-t-h-e
okay which one e-t-h-e
oh right it's a short-term trade right
yeah it's big trend i'm going to close
it today e-t-h-e
okay so gabrielle found an etf for us
but it's already an etf it's a it's a
fan okay so it's different but if it's
short-term trade you will be fine okay
so let's see if i have the permission to
trade that
the price is same around 25 guys
everything is worth 25
uh so we can adapt our order easily
no training permission
i cannot let me check on my side
i don't
okay no let me try override and transmit
no i'm not information
[ __ ] it
i cannot
i can't do it as well okay but let's
leave it like that okay guys we tried
didn't work but we tried there's another
one which is gonna be on the canadian
exchange okay let's check
it's ethh let me check if i can do this
one
i'm gonna call interactive broker after
this live so tomorrow i'm gonna be fully
set up if i want to do that again guys
with you
day trade some crypto is fun i hope you
like it
on the canadian exchange i can do it
having said that you kind of have some
kind of effects because
it's fine just say
so let's see if i can do that
nah not shooting permission okay i
really need to okay i cannot let's leave
it like that it's fine
we already have all the places
it's not gonna change much especially
uh what i showed you guys is very valid
on the medium term all right this you
know um
premium of bitcoin right now compared to
the ethereum
uh
the wolf of palama
cc
[Music]
kemler in the place
and um
and yeah
for the day trading it's fine to to make
some um
to go to the to the bitcoin trade
especially that we don't have these
permissions today so let's not make
things too complicated
all right let's follow a little bit what
is happening on jme guys we are getting
back close to this
20 period moving average
on the 30 minutes time frame
so let's see if
we're able to take it back guys
okay
okay i'm gonna check milan give me just
a second
eating my breakfast my second breakfast
okay so on milan guys um like a saddle
okay maybe we can do a day trade here we
didn't
do anything today yet
um and milan is getting back to the
support
but as you guys know i like to have
really a good consolidation to enter my
trades
here it's
it's not too bad
it's not too bad
[Music]
i'm not a big fan of the setup
because
the momentum is broken we are below the
you know on the hourly time frame we are
below the 20 and 50 000 moving averages
uh so in the very short term i'm not a
big fan if we get back
close to
you know 118 i mean it's very far it
won't be looking good as well
it's not easy to get in
okay without taking
uh without making it a gamble all right
if you want to use technical analysis
properly and enter this trade
unfortunately there is nothing using my
methods i see here
the reason being that we broke
out below this moving averages that are
to me important
okay even on the first time frame you
can see okay we are testing the
20 period moving average here
so it's rather bullish but it's not a
good setup for me to to to make a trade
so we'll wait a bit
okay i'm seeing gme guys as expected so
it's good guys we are
like i said
taking back some energy
um just corrects me a little bit on low
volume
okay look at the volume today it's a
boring day
nothing much is happening we didn't take
position but
for now we did we wouldn't have made
any real profits
because it's not moving a lot tomorrow i
think it's going to be more exciting
it's the option expiry
tomorrow we gonna be there of course
again
okay i have a question
i didn't see this one
if a recession happens and the market
was to crash how low do you think the
spi will fall so okay
i can make just two scenarios one
bearish scenario and one
uh you know cataclysmic scenario all
right
so for now we just had
a small i mean
it's a correction
let's see for a correction to be valid
we need to correct at least 28
of the last move up so the last move up
is here
on spy and we went to the 38.2 percent
so this correction might very well be
over now a deeper correction would go to
the 61.8 retracement so it would go to
the 380 level
so um i think that if things turn bad
we'll probably go back to 380.
now if we have
really something extremely bad happening
uh
it's very hard to say
i don't want to make it's too early to
discuss this kind of things so
i would say
380 is for now the worst case scenario i
can see
on the spy
all right given how the economy is
strong given everything we have right
now
uh it doesn't make sense to make any
other scenario so for now bitcoin is
keeps going higher guys
let's see if the volume is still here on
the 15 minutes time frame
okay we had a nice volume but right now
you see it's not followed by strong
volume
uh
okay
let's check in the past
okay those volumes can be much bigger
guys so
the volume is here but it's not
impressive
okay i have a question about amc guys so
of course
uh
we keep an eye on it no alex
amc looks good guys um you can check at
the beginning of this video i made an
update on an
amc and gme and i was saying that those
are in control guys on the short term i
mean if you look at the daily time frame
it's pretty obvious
this is nothing this is just a smooth
deep on low volume we want this volume
to be as low as possible today if we see
that at the end of the day
bears are intensifying you know their
orders
then we would of course need to take
this into account for now it's not
happening for now booze that completely
in control on the short term
i mean on the very short term best to
back control but it's just a smooth back
and as long as the volume stays low and
the moves are contained
i don't see any reason the bullish
momentum to stop so we'll probably keep
grinding higher
the next resistance is so once again
20.6 22 25.5 those supports those
resistance are here guys
they're good to use
for
you know taking profits or selling
covered calls for those who want to do
that for those who just want to buy and
hold it's very good as well guys
um
because you know
doing some
buy and selling emc's really
tricky game i don't advise to do that
okay bitcoin at 44
000. okay
oh yeah we can have a look at x guys oh
yeah we didn't go through the watch list
today let's do that right now
okay so this is the watch list i'm using
to you know create my alerts that i post
on discord
and
okay so as you can see i'm monitoring
some levels that are in the yellow
column
and sometimes i'm monitoring if we
arrive close to this level from the lows
then it's a stop limit all the type that
i put here or if we are coming back to a
support level from the highs then it's a
limit order that i would i would set up
and i would try to buy the dip and if we
are close to my levels that i enter
manually it creates an alert all right
so today's alerts
are here
okay so we have all of that so we've
been through most of them
but let's do that again so mara oh
bitcoin is breaking out guys we have
riot we have mara so let's check those
two first i know that you guys like the
stocks
let's see what they do i remember i did
mara on tuesday i think and we were
monitoring the 122 level
so let's see today
you see okay we don't have the signal
yet on mara definitely
okay
i mean we could
see things like this as well
you see technically she can always do
different things so maybe we can see
that this is a breakout but if this was
a breakout
we would need to see a volume increase
which we don't i mean this is not a real
volume increase so for now mara doesn't
give
any signal
of reversal
uh
even if bitcoin does
so you know it's good to keep everything
in mind together
i'm a bit surprised by the way that mara
is late like that
because as you can see mara was trading
here
in jan 22 higher than that
and in jan 22 bitcoin was
again not the same okay
no no it makes sense
okay so for now mara like we said we
don't see any clear setup we are still
not looking so great to me as long as
we're below this red trend line and this
uh blue trend land that is here this one
so we're monitoring the 32 level okay
guys then what else do we have today
okay d e keeps going higher guys so this
was a nice breakout that we have
identified but it happened without
volume so it was a bit risky
okay for nothing new nothing new
fissile guys for those who like the
stock we monitor the 6h level
okay we start to have a nice
consideration for me here guys
okay so this is interesting
let's see what happens here guys
okay six ninety level maybe the pitch
break
okay then we have x guys
[Applause]
bam keeping grounding hi guys so this
was
a breakout that has been identified on a
weekly time frame
and as you can see it is still
it is still looking very good bam bam
bam going higher
so the target is 47 here i would say for
x we entered this trade around 23.
[Music]
okay
all right yeah so what else do we have
here
so x is looking good still you know
grinding higher probably going to go to
45 we have a position here we're happy
to keep it
tpc tpic i can have a look at that as
well guys
i'm just checking if i have new
uh
new
alerts to give i don't
okay so i can check tpic
maybe we're gonna find something cool
okay it's still very weak like we have
time here as you can see we are uh
i mean
we're on a downtrend
since february 21
and okay we are start to see some
reversal signs but uh
but we don't have
i mean we had the volume increase that
happened here okay we can see this as a
breakout fair enough
okay here
i agree
but i mean it's
it's for now an early signal okay we
it's not enough to really turn bullish
here we can check in the past
how things happen i would rather wait so
it's a bit far i know but i would rather
wait to see what is happening around
this trend line so maybe we can go you
know back close to this area
to the 20 area for now booze and control
in the short term all right so if you
want to see if you want to have some uh
buying levels i would say
that anything close to 12 is good to buy
you see the 50-day moving average seems
to be acting well as resistance
seems to be yeah acting well as recent
in the past it got broken here and now
it it could act as support so let's see
if uh it can
it can be used to entry i think uh not
too it's not a bad
uh it's not the bad setup
but like i said we have some resistance
here a bit higher so
i don't think it's the best setup right
now we have
okay let's quickly have a look again at
amc and jimmy guys
so here as you can see
still like low volume
no big moves even here we had some
strong reaction from the bulls but it
happened on very low volume all right so
this is confirming the fact that for now
uh you know
i don't think we're gonna see anything
crazy today
um because even when we have this
you know rebound they don't happen with
high volume the volume is just
decreasing
uh
which is just showing that you know we
have
i think time tomorrow is going to be
another day today is a calm day
ideally it would be good to close you
know
somewhere around 20.5
you know just to put pressure on the
best
uh it would be better
okay so what else do we have guys
so i am pp okay i can check that
okay so this stock is not moving much
guys uh i mean
here i think it was
i guess there was an ipo here i don't
know
we had some the volume started to arrive
here in february 22. so let's check what
is the stock first i don't know this uh
ticker i mpp
okay imperial petroleum ink explosion
produces biodiesel and oil and gas
okay
so then i'm going to have a look at an i
o
alright so uh
okay
so impp first imp guys i don't know it's
just
not moving a lot we have some phone
coming back it's very difficult to make
some technical analysis on this uh
on this particular
stock because i don't see any strong
moves here
okay guys so uh
nioh and ayo let's have a look at that
guys i know this is a hot stuff guys
so
what do we have we
we dropped a lot
uh
i had some levels
around
my last support level was here at 16.6
so we went
a little bit through this level
but then booze managed to take back
control for now bez is still in control
we have this first trend line that is
here
uh bam bam bam
[Music]
okay if i use a logarithmic scale it's
more visible
something is happening around this level
but we don't have any real consolidation
here that is telling us that the strong
line is the one that is needs to be
broken we had some nice volume increase
indeed
so that's good but once again the volume
increase that is not happening on a
breakout is not as reliable as a volume
increase that is happening when a big
level is taken back
so um
so let's see guys what we can see here
but i guess that if we managed to close
above 22 23 it would be looking good
so um but for now i don't know pretty
much neutral on that
it's gonna go together i guess with
tesla as well
nice coffee
still
okay still
nile to do bkktc okay i can have a look
at that guys come on we're close to 100
likes
smash that like button guys
it's good for the channel
all right so
and then you just let me conclude the
nao so i can see what resistance around
22.
so let's see if we can take this back
but seriously though
you know i prefer to play this long term
uh so of course it's better to enter
at a very good level but
you know at the height at the low level
but here we have some resistance at 35
all right so even if we manage to go you
know above that
here we're gonna have a big question i
prefer to wait for that
you know be patient so maybe a few
months
uh
let the price action do what it has to
do and then if you have some
consolidation and then a breakout here i
would be a buyer and this would be
probably followed by a strong wrap so i
don't want to stock my money for now in
something that is not really hot
and
um so let's wait i think that nio you
can try to enter but you have also some
downside as you can see so to me it's
not the best uh play at the moment
all right bkkt
i don't know if i did that one before
yes
okay so resistance at eight same thing i
don't see any real trading setup we
don't have any consideration easy to
trade
maybe we had one here
you can see
but it's not i don't know
we have support at
six right now but the consideration is
not very strong uh
i don't know it's not a good trading
setup to me first resistance is that
eight and we need to wait to see more
press action to me here we have volume
coming back but they're still low
uh nothing much to say on this one
neutral neutral between five and eight
above eight i start to look at it
okay
n-i-l-e
this one is a new one i think
i know i've done that
big nine holdings what's that let's
check guys
so investment holding company the
company three subsidiaries okay so it's
a whole investment technician technology
platform services architecture as well
as owns and operates
okay okay
so it's holding and i don't know rsi you
can see
resisting at 50 remember that guys on
rsi above 50 is bullish and rsi below 50
is bearish i mean it's not enough but
it's just one more thing to add to the
analysis
here we are not able to close above 50
on the daily time frame on the rsi
so since actually here right so since
this october 21 bears and control and if
you see the rsi coming back and holding
above 50
then you can start to be like okay i
will maybe start to buy some chests but
before that
i don't think it's a good idea it will
of course probably go together with
other signals like a breakout that you
could have here for now you don't have
it so the levels to watch are roughly
0.9 on the upside
okay guys
so it's a very calm day guys i
i think i'm not gonna
you know stay here
uh the whole session
so if you have some more questions ask
me now guys we're gonna end this live
within 10-15 minutes
we're of course going to keep an eye on
everything that is happening we didn't
do any order today we still have our
order placed on bitcoin but i don't
think it will pull back right now it's
gonna pull back probably later i don't
think we're gonna just rally like that
maybe but
uh yeah bbig has been done but i can do
it again
um
so bbig quickly
i mean nothing's happening on bb you
know
we are just
waiting above this
support
all right hey
ah okay
okay so you can see guys we are just
consolidating around this level but
the trend i'm having is not perfect like
i said so i'm not very happy about this
uh
you know drawings but it's the best i
can do
um 360 is the first resistance okay
but then we have four so we have an
area of resistance that we have here so
i mean if you look at trend lines you
don't have good information coming from
this but if you look at the volume we
have indeed the volume kicking in but
then
it didn't follow what happened here guys
is that the flows from and we've seen
that before we've seen that with dewalt
with phn
uh with many you know meme stocks that
are squeezing and
basically the flows go from
those
kind of new squeeze to amc amigas all
right so
it's just
you know amc and gme are attracting
everything today so as long as those two
are attracting the volume the volume is
not somewhere else uh look at me for
example you know i you know prefer to
of course my situation is a bit
different i do it for you but even if i
was training myself i would
today uh prefer to buy mcdme of course
because i mean we can we can see that
everything can happen that maybe
tomorrow we're going to be up 20 we
don't have the same feeling on milan
bbig we think that things are now calm
maybe it's going to come back but for
now the volume is low
and in terms of uh support resistance we
are in a neutral area guys we can very
well go to four all right it's possible
which is a nice move up
but we have a resistance at four if we
close above four then we discuss then
we're gonna have a look at it better and
you know but for now i don't know it's
just
very calm to me
okay
the watch i can do direct guys i was in
that trade but i took profit
i entered at 62 to profit at 95.
okay
so you see it's just oscillating
i didn't buy it back at 62. it came back
here
very low volume
so that's pretty good okay i'm gonna
monitor you but guys thank you for
giving me this one
i'm gonna add it in the watch list
because you can see how here we have a
very nice consideration happening on low
volume
on a level i had already before
but
you know
interestingly it's attracted by it again
so let's try to be precise here where is
the breakout level it's roughly here
okay
so around 17.3 so i'm gonna add this to
the watch these guys and i'm gonna
monitor that
if i have a breakout i will post an
alert in my discord
as usual i didn't post anything for the
past two three days guys it's just
because i have nothing
okay i'm not gonna post something if i
don't believe in it
okay so d work above 73.5
okay
bam add it to the watch list
okay so c e and n
last one
okay so volume increase
we keep moving higher
no consideration so that's
not once again a good trading setup
uh but the volumes are nice
booze and control i don't see any
resistance close
to where we are
so
so once again so i think this could be
used
to
you know you can make some day trading
maybe here
if we find some moving averages yes we
have the hourly moving average that is
respected quite well in the very recent
past
just here now it's a bit slowing
so i don't know i don't like to see that
guys this is not a bullish setup you can
see we have a price action going higher
on decreasing volume
decreasing momentum okay so this is a
signal of reversal all right so here i
would be careful i would definitely not
buy now
because we have some very signals on the
short term uh so let's try to find the
next support levels
if we have a move down
because investors take profit now you
can see this move is just slowing
so the next support level that's the
problem when you don't have
consolidation is that you know where you
don't really know where the support
levels i would say it's around 2.2
and next one is around here right so
between 1.8 and 2
so in this area this is a buying area
okay
all right
above that i would not buy and here we
have the resistance which is quite high
so you know the volume are increasing so
maybe we can push towards this area
it seems a bit far to be honest uh but
why not
why not
okay guys all right last one bbby and
then i'm done
and we've done that yesterday
so
pretty calm today
minus two percent
uh nothing much to say guys here it's a
bit messy to me i don't like
uh
i don't know i don't understand this
price action
i don't see clearly where the bells were
the balls all right here definitely
there were balls on this trend line but
now we are moving but we're moving
higher get sold i mean
not easy to trade supports are
17.7
then 13 okay so this is a buying area
and then here we have some resistance
okay guys i'm done for today thank you
very much thank you very much for
watching
uh we're gonna be here tomorrow of
course guys same hour for the open uh
we're gonna discuss about amc jamie
tomorrow is gonna be a big day i have
this feeling guys
because everything is looking good we're
just consolidating on low volume we
still have this massive option expiry
so maybe i'm gonna take some position
before the close if i do i will let you
know in my discord guys
uh but for now i don't see anything so
thank you very much much love guys hit
that like button if you didn't yet and i
see you tomorrow cheers guys